now there is yet another apprentice
contestant who says Trump sexually
assaulted me summer zervos is a former
contestant on season 5 of The Apprentice
she came forward couple of days ago with
new accusations of sexual assault on
behalf of Republican nominee Donald
Trump Zervos said very specifically that
Trump thrusted his genitals on her she
spoke about an incident where she had
lunch with Trump and he kissed her on
the lips twice this is not what I wanted
or expected she said adding that her
friend and parents were also told about
this and were able to corroborate the
incident in a statement later Friday
Trump of course denied ever having met
zervos I'm sorry ever having greeted
Zervos inappropriately or meeting her in
a hotel as she claimed of course we have
corroboration some reserve of spoke to
her father immediately after the
incident in terms of her politics not
really a motive to discredit some
reserve oh she is a Republican she made
that very clear at a press conference
that she gave and Gloria Allred was at
the press conference with summer Zervos
she says that she has been contacted by
many more women alleging sexual assault
about Donald Trump asked whether they
would be speaking out going public she
said I can't answer that question at
this time ladies and gentlemen this is
what Donald Trump said he does write
saying when you're a star they let you
do it you can get away with anything
Trump at least thinks that they let him
do it some reservo said it was not at
all what she wanted but Trump said when
I see a beautiful woman I can't help it
I just start kissing her and so many
people email me saying oh you should be
super skeptical of these claims Trump
told us this is what he does and women
are confirming Trump's own statements
the fact that women are coming forward
to confirm that what Trump said he does
he's actually done that's called
corroboration when women get out of hand
I slap them around imagine someone said
when women get out of hand I slap them
around and then women come forward and
they say you know what this guy slapped
me around that's not something that we
should say wow it sounds crazy it
doesn't make any sense and of course a
lot of
people emailing me pat saying oh we
can't believe any of these women well
they're saying exactly what Trump
himself said he does yeah and then his
audacity to call them liars too I mean
this is the reason why a lot of women
who are sexually assaulted don't come
out right away because they're gonna be
attacked and called Liars by the media
and everyone else and we've heard those
stories from a lot of these women have
we have yes yeah